[Music]
shares an emotional tribute to her late
husband greg leaks
i would just like to say i love you so
much
in the video nene posted to instagram on
thursday the couple looks happy as they
dance to johnny gills it would be
[Music]
you greg died this week following a
battle with colon cancer
you have been my light i couldn't do
this without you i couldn't i wouldn't
even try
so i want to thank you baby
nene received an outpouring of support
across social media
andy cohen took to twitter with his
condolences writing quote i am
heartbroken over the passing of greg
leaks a wonderful man i jokingly called
him pastor leaks but in truth he was a
strong voice of reason and commanded
great respect among the entire real
housewives of atlanta team i am sending
love and strength to nene leakes and the
entire leakes family
nene's former castmate portia williams
shared her well wishes during an
instagram live prayers
to the whole leaks family this is
definitely a difficult time
and we definitely are sending them all
of our love and all of our prayers
another one of nene's former castmates
cynthia bailey wrote on twitter that
she's heartbroken over greg's death and
called out what a loving funny and kind
man he was
nicki minaj also lent her support
sharing this message to her instagram
story she wrote in part quote though i
know nothing can stop the pain you must
be feeling right now i'm sending you
love and strength
greg was diagnosed with stage 3 colon
cancer in 2018
but the following year nene announced
that greg was cancer-free after
undergoing treatment
question i have
is the type of cancer that greg has
the stage that he's at
is it common that is beatable i would
use chemotherapy at this point to try to
reduce that risk of the cancer coming
back greg's battle against cancer played
out on the real housewives of atlanta
but
you never know what's in you until
you're at that door
[Music]
never thought i had it in me to fight
cancer
and in 2019 nene opened up to e.t about
sharing that journey on tv
what was it like to get the response
from the fans and the viewers who are
maybe going through the same thing you
and greg and your family is going well i
can say that i had a lot of fans to
reach out to me caretakers were emailing
me left and right saying we understand
what you are going through now there
were people who did not understand what
a caretaker role is or they just didn't
understand me saying i was frustrated
they were like why are you frustrated
you're not the one with cancer but you
know i was frustrated because i was a
caretaker